and action
good I like this this is going
to be good hi I'm mat bers from
the Seattle kraak hey hey what
do you say and let's break some
[Music]
stuff when I first walked in I saw the
ice blocks I was like these are thick
are these going to break with
a wrist shot might take a slap
[Music]
shot that was nice I like that
you need to relieve some stress
maybe that's a great thing for
hockey players to do the tape
machine that one built pretty
sturdy I want to put one R shot through that TV
though
I would do that for
fun I'm going to go buy a bunch of
those just set them up in my house good
[Music] break thank you very much that was
fun
what